hey there I was like telling people what
to do and or maybe no then boy do we
have a job for you
foundation security officer it's our
belief that feckless d-class shouldn't
be given an inch of breathing room are
generally living breathing human filth
that's where you come in we give you a
list of duties for the day and the rest
is up to you for instance if you get
orders to guard a containment chamber
and have some [ __ ] upstart trying to
escape have some fun
see how many times you can kick him in
his lovemaker until he passes out shoot
him in the foot and order in to run a
mile and fold him and push him down a
flight of stairs shout insults at him
and see if he cries just kill the [ __ ]
disposable for a reason so what are you
waiting for sign up for the security
officer position today and start having
the time of your [ __ ] life
guaranteed does exist apply and
protected applications maybe recorder to
monitor the dream process make us x
nausea vomiting I don't know [ __ ]
systems precisely so you dr. green in
the middie may be required DCP
foundation is regulating control over
five times
you
you